oh it's Friday night there's so much
going on uh Jim Jordan was stabbed in
the back in a secret ballot they voted
him out so a lot of interesting things
happening there's still no speaker of
the house we'll see what happens there
Joe Biden cashed a $200,000 check from
his brother which directly links him to
the Shady business dealings of his
family oh yeah we well he said wasn't
involved or any of that but now we have
what appears to be or what many people
are alleging is money laundering
Marjorie Taylor green herself actually
says that this is a money that was
laundered and in very big news ladies
and gentlemen Fox News has filed a
copyright strike against us now here's
what you need to understand when someone
infringes your copyright and you file a
claim against them you get two options a
takedown or a strike you can go and say
I want this this removed it violates our
copyright or you can say I want them to
receive a hard strike for for stealing
my content Fox gave us a hard strike I
believe and they've also done this to
David Pacman a couple weeks ago two
weeks ago now David Pacman had his video
uh hit by a copyright strike I believe
this is an an egregious abuse of the
system I believe that what we did was
absolutely fair use in any logical
respect and the idea that Fox News
thinks that they should have a monopoly
on a pres on people trying to be the
president more
importantly our factchecking and
commenting on what these individuals are
saying in real time they're arguing no
one should be allowed to do that Fox
News crossed the line now with this
strike there is no immediate impact to
our Channel everything's fine however
they're basically threatening us if we
do this again if we dare try to fact
check any of the Republican candidates
the second strike has serious
implications and would shut this showed
down on YouTube for 3 months so we'll
talk more about that but this is this is
a major development which I
believe is is is potential has a
potential to go to the Supreme Court
we'll talk all about that because that's
probably going to be a that this is a
huge story as we enter 20124 this is
going to be a have a massive impact on
how special interests can manipulate the
election by selectively choosing who can
and can't comment on and fact check
president cial debates we'll get into
all that before we get started my
friends head over to K Keno wood sorry I
pronounce it wrong kenwood.com one of
our members has this excellent wood
company whatever you want to call it
custom wood designs they got chuder
boards really really cool custom
furniture that you can call in and
commission look how beautiful these hard
maple end grain Butcher Block is if you
want to support our members then go to
kenwood.com the link is in the
description below and shout out to to
all our members uh every Friday we're
shouting out our members who help make
the show possible so if you have a
company and you're a member sign up at
timcast.net
for uh uh you know if you have a project
you're working on as a member you get
access to our uncensored membersonly
shows Monday through Thursday as well as
our Discord app where you can sign up
hang out with like-minded individuals
there's pre-shows there's after shows
there's weekend shows and you can submit
questions and call into the uncensored
members only show and as members we
periodically shout out our members so if
uh if you want to be a member then uh
support our work directly timcast.net
talk about this and a whole lot more is
Lauren witzky hello hello thank you so
much for having me it's an honor who are
you what do you do oh my name is Lauren
witzky I am currently the executive
producer for the St Peters Network I was
the Republican nominee for United States
Senate back in 2020 and I'm the producer
behind the movie died suddenly and watch
the water right on thanks for hanging
out it should be fun we got cter Banks
hanging out sup
guys that's it he's a music producer
here at timcast here at timcast um doing
stuff with trash house so the The Carter
is is popping in on Fridays because of
our top secret music project uh no
because we actually I don't know if we
we don't have a camera set up for that
right now do we got a couple actually
but I mean is it on is it ready can you
can you switch to it jump you right now
right so we're actually oh wow that
looks amazing got three going ready to
go yeah we're actually we've had this
like music set up for a long time we've
never set it up but now the plan is
Fridays we're actually going to start
having uh music that be pretty sweet
look at that musical guests and yep so
we're going to have a music Friday
nights we we did this a while ago and it
was it was more just like we would just
Jam On acoustic but now the idea is when
we can if we can we will have musical
guests so we're hoping that Friday we'll
get there there's a lot of really
awesome you know popular prominent
musicians who are starting to get very
political and so we're looking forward
to having them come and hang out with us
obviously Phil leonti is on the show
he's currently out of town working on
his uh his new album I believe but uh
we're hoping to have you know him and
whoever else come and and play some
songs for us and it's going to be really
awesome so yeah we got Libby hanging out
hey I'm back I'm Libby Emmons with the
post-millennial and human events filling
in for Ian yet again who is Ian's on
vacation who is on vacation Lucky Dog
what happened was he messaged me saying
that he's doing um what is that what is
that training they're doing where they
like run through the woods with guns or
something that sounds kind of fun yeah
tactical no he's doing some kind of like
tactical training with Luke and so he
hits me up and he's like this this is
amazing and he's at the gym with Luke
and and I'm like Ian started working out
and he's turning into a conserver bro
that's amazing he's praying to Jesus
he's doing gun training he's exing he's
praying to Jesus he said that on the
show that he prayed to Jesus for the
first time that's true wow yeah yeah he
did him heing can make you Christian
that's working out makes you
conservative I love it well so while
he's out of town on his you know uh
spiritual Quest liby's here we got
search pressing the buttons yeah I am
here I'm excited to do this music stuff
too it'll be fun man
uh yeah that's very cool let's just jump
into it I'm also covering for Kell on
Fridays now so all right here we go from
the post millennial Joe Biden cashed
$200,000 check from brother James
business deal house investigators reveal
now the check says loan repayment which
is funny because how do you track the
record of when was a loan given was it
even a loan so there's a lot to break
down before we even read any of this
I'll just say very simply what this
shows is this ch you know it could be
completely on the level maybe maybe Jo
just gave his brother a loan right
that's all it was okay here here brother
here's money for you it shows that Joe
is directly involved in the finances and
the business dealings that his brother's
engaged in this is his brother going
James going to Joe and saying I need a
loan for insert project and Joe saying
you got it which makes Joe the financier
of these things that is the best case
scenario for Joe that all he did is help
Finance his brother's business dealings
or something a component of what his
brother's involved in you can make the
argument oh maybe it's personal no I I I
don't accept that because when Donald
Trump was doing tried to get the G7 at
Trump Durell arguing that he would do it
at Cost with no profit everyone on the
left and even me we we all said no it's
still a direct payment which benefits
Trump's companies this right here is
still a direct payment benefiting his
brother who is engaged in these Shady
business dealings it I think at at the
bare minimum shows his brothers involved
now the worst case scenar of course is
Joe's getting paid off now now when you
look at the hard evidence and you can
see 10% for the big guy and all that I
think it is clear now you connect the
dots this is circumstantial evidence
that when they said 10% for the big guy
when they were talking about paying Joe
Biden a loan repayment could this be
what Hunter was talking about when he
said his dad takes half his salary could
this be the fee paid to Joe a loan for
his name
now what actually is pointed out in the
article is that the reason so what
happens is americor gives James Biden a
loan James then that day writes a
$200,000 check to Joe which looks like
money laundering yeah and it says it
says loan repayment on the check which
is um there's no way to know as yet if
Biden had actually given his brother a
loan so comr James comr wants to know
whether Biden has the documents to prove
that he had lent $200,000 to his brother
um whether he had similar arrangements
with other family members and Marjorie
Taylor green said exactly what you said
Carter that it's a classic example of
moneyer I mean yeah I didn't want to
overstep with that but he looks exactly
like that well if if and and it's so
it's so overt I mean come on look it
might not be but when def like fa okay
americore was failing and apparently out
of business but still had money in the
coffers writes a check for $200,000 to
James who then instantly that day writes
$200,000 for Biden it looks like
americore is giving Biden money yes it
sure does look like that and also the
other thing too is if it's not a loone
repayment we have the situation where
Donald Trump is being tried in New York
by Alvin Bragg on what is it like 37
counts of falsification of business
records so could this perhaps be if if
Biden didn't give his brother a loan
then this is the falsification of a
business record did it go down a good
point yeah did it go down in his taxes
as a loan repayment how has this been
Quantified what are his book bookkeeping
records looking like if Trump is being
brought up on these charges um it's a
civil suit against Trump but basically I
was I saw this I started laughing I'm
like oh so everything they accused Trump
of doing they did right and they said
well that was that was a criminal that's
a criminal case the Alvin brag one is
Criminal oh I mean in in the civil case
in New York where they're arguing he
falsified business records yeah that
Alvin brag one that's that's isn't that
criminal no it's a civil suit it's I
don't know if it's the Leticia James in
New York that's a civil suit the Alvin
BR of bus
what I'm saying is the suit against
Trump right now by laa James is a
lawsuit to determine whether Trump
falsified business records right and
Alvin Bragg has a similar case yeah but
the F that that one was about stormmy
Daniels wasn't it yeah it was about the
money that Trump paid to Michael Cohen
and then Cohen paid money to Stormy
Daniels so this is very much like that
one and this is very much like that lock
him up lock him up Joe's got to go they
the rules not us and we you know we are
humbler humble followers of those laws
so man you know it really breaks my
heart to say this but we're going to
have to arrest Joe Biden and you know
he's going to have to go to jail well I
would love to see the Department of
Justice actually do that let's get the
FBI involved they should really start
digging in correct the only way isn't
that what's up now like raid his house
okay let's go for it do you want to see
Joe Biden get arrested right now for
this cuz I can tell no no I can tell you
exactly how you can see it if you want
to see Joe Biden there is one way that
you can see him right now get arrested
for this it's called mid Journey you
just type in the prompts Jo Biden get
arrested that's the only way you're ever
going to see cens arrest in Georgia or
something like that no just AI generated
images and then you can fantasize and
pretend like the world is actually safe
and there's accountability but uh you
know other than that have fun that's
like how my mom used to always watch The
West Wing she was just obsessed with she
was like this is how I just fantasize
reality oh that's so sad the reality the
reality of the internal workings of the
White House is probably oh right now
with Biden is probably so dark like they
what did they find they found crack
right or I was just thinking about that
what cocaine in the in the white house
somewhere in the I grew up so I grew up
with the Biden like Dynasty ruling over
my state for years and years and it's
like well known it's just like kind of
public knowledge that they're like super
corrupt the bidens run everything you
can't get past anything and their kids
are a mess too like was that the was
that the story on Bo Biden as well was
he considered
was like the Beloved you know but also
he had a lot
of backdoor stuff going on between like
northern Delaware and Southern Delaware
and like paying off politicians for
Bridges and Road repairs and stuff like
that so there was a lot of like even
corruption back then I wouldn't say he
was a man of character um based on what
I know of him but the Biden's like I saw
what he did to the bidens did to my
state it's almost unlivable now in some
parts and yeah and I'm watching him do
it to America as soon as he was elected
president I said oh boy not good so no
this is interesting uh uh Michael super
chated saying loan repayment in the memo
was was uh not written by the same
person oh you think well I don't know
about that I mean the Super Chat did but
if uh I've got the picture right here so
if you uh if you take a look the
argument is that the writing for 200,000
and Z you know 100 uh and loan repayment
are different
I don't know what do you guys think I
think they look they look the same to me
but I certainly am no handwriting
expert I was blasting a stink bug I
don't like those guys you don't like
them they're funny I know they just
smell bad they and they clap I know
they're great there's one hanging out in
my kitchen at home right now actually
but um yeah it doesn't look the same to
me it looks looks pretty different the
lowercase te's kind of look different do
they where's there a lowercase tea at
the very end in loan repayment and
then it looks like there's a capital T
in
Thousand yeah I don't know I mean I'm
not a handwriting expert but they you
know they they said that they're more
angles what did they say uh the writing
has more of an
angle I can see that actually the
repayment is written with a slight angle
to the right meaning at the very least
if they wrote 200,000 they shifted the
check as they wrote again giving it a
rightward angle angle to their
handwriting but they but anyway if that
were true and I'm sure they're
handwriting experts who can either just
bunk or debunk it then um the the
implication being made here and I I
don't know if that has any Merit the
implication is that uh when Joe received
the check he wrote loan repayment on it
himself right or someone else did
someone just wanted to make sure that
they literally dotted their eyes and C
their this is not a payment it's a
repayment it's a loan repayment maybe
maybe it just said loan payment you know
I don't think we're going to get
anything from this no you know uh yeah
they're going to say look it's a brother
lent his money his brother some money
that's all it is I think that a lot of
this stuff I mean I think that what
keeps happening is that the House GOP
has the goods on Joe Biden and it's just
not going to go anywhere no matter how
much um no matter even though they have
the majority they don't really have any
power at this point in Congress um the
Democrats have a lot of power to you
know they went along with Matt Gates you
know in the uh outing of McCarthy
whether you like that or not you know
that they did that um that was a the
Democrats had all the power there over
the majority of the GOP which was my
main concern about the outing of
McCarthy was like it just sort of gives
up the GOP power what what what was
there well even when they didn't have
that much anyway yeah I mean that's sort
of the thing we don't use it we don't
wield our political power ever we're
well known for being like the losers
because they can't raise money if
they're like if they're winning you know
that's that's the thing when you say we
it's like no no no no like the The
neocon shill Establishment Republicans
are not us or not you they're they're
the reason they don't wield their they
wield their power against you right so
when everyone's like why won't the
Republicans do anything no no no you
don't understand they're using all of
their might and power to crush you the
person who voted for them well they're
still just doing that uni party thing
and that's why it's the moderates now
who are like in a position to make deals
with Democrats GH it's pretty gross it's
pretty gross but that's the concern is
that we're not going to get anything out
of this no matter how many smoking guns
they bring no matter how many yeah like
direct how much direct evidence of
bribery there is we're not going to see
um accountability from the Biden family
plus the B like Biden's going to be out
I don't think any of us think that he's
actually going to be president for the
next term you know like they're do you
think they're going to run somebody else
I don't know I mean I just don't see how
he could
possibly serve another four years he can
barely
I saw a video of him the other day and I
didn't even it it was very weird it
looked like a robot from Disney World
kind of well he does the old man
dementia Shuffle very slow and like the
it's the shuffle it's the like I'm
afraid to fall down thing you have his
staff saying outright that part of their
job is to make sure that he doesn't fall
down we see him fall down anyways um
it's like we were talking the other
night about when he does give speeches
when he gives big speeches it's like it
almost seems like he's a different man
than when he's just off the cuff he
doesn't seem all there he shakes hands
with the air it's very bizarre to see
this man um who's so
clearly losing losing it to old age he's
not really making any of the decisions
though it's probably the Biden administ
or the Obama Administration like kind of
pulling the strings making the decision
they just need a face guy and they
haven't picked anybody else yet to run
they Nome is making some noise he was he
um he said he was going to go travel
around to Israel you know which is like
a a face opportunity hokel did that as
well from New York she went there I
think she said she went there the day
before Biden did um but I just don't see
I don't see how he could possibly do it
so I mean if he's just going to be
propped up if it's going to be like you
know Weekend at Bernie's the White
House don't you think the American
people are going to be aware of that
like why would we well I've talked to a
few Democrats too that even say that
he's too old like they just like man I
think he needs to retire he's getting
too old but the concern is Cala Harris
is second in line so and she is the most
disliked candidate most disliked
politician probably in American history
like they had no reason to CH like
choose her to run like she was in a deep
blue State of California and they still
put her with Joe Biden for the sake I
guess of diversity however she is very
unliked very unliked and it just didn't
make any sense I wonder if they're going
to switch out a VP for him you know that
would be more likely what I think I
think they're going to try and run him
but make a really likable vice president
that way people can feel confident
voting like how they swap him out gets
too old like can't you switch out your
vice presidential candidate in the next
election wouldn't he wouldn't that be an
issue in of itself like now if you put
like Gavin Newsome or something running
as VP with Biden people would vote for
that Dem would need she would like for
her to go along with that she would need
some exit strategy that gives her a a
better position than vice president and
I feel like she'd have to make that
decision by herself too and be like you
know what I want to spend more time with
my family even though she barely has
come something you know some kind of
payout or something to salvage her
dignity or reputation but that's the
thing I don't think that uh Democrats
are really confident in a Joe Biden pres
presidency with Camala being the one I
was even concerned when they were
talking about impeaching Biden cuz I
don't want Kamala is going to be 10
times worse like she is oh she's
terrible I mean nuts yeah yeah she's
unburdened by what might have been well
let's let's let's let's talk about the
uh the big story that's affecting us
directly we have this uh from my Twitter
account and that's it Fox News filed a
copyright strike on our goop debate
commentary taking the whole episode down
and I will say immediately as we begin
the segment I believe that what we did
was absolutely fair use we were uh uh
first of all this is the public has a
right to know what's going on with these
debates it is newsworthy what these
individuals are saying we were
commenting directly on what was being
said and the show itself it was direct
commentary on this combine those things
and I think that
immediately this is a matter of our
democracy as they like to say right
so the argument would be that Fox News
can host presidential candidates who can
say things that only they are allowed to
filter to the American public and no one
else is allowed to fact check what they
are saying now their argument is you can
fact check them but you can't just show
what they've said in in real time I
reject that that would mean that
everyone has to watch only their
interpretation and it creates a
circumstance in which they can
selectively choose to take down only
specific commentary it would be
impossible to take down everyone who's
providing commentary which means there
will always be the argument that oh but
uh you know they they infringe on our
copyright so we took them down it's okay
okay hold on the guy critical of
candidate one was taken down but the guy
critical of candidate 2 was not oh we
must have missed it that creates a
loophole that will require that you
actually can't do anything about to to
be completely honest I think this
President can't stand because uh right
now as it stands I can't sue Fox News
simply for filing a claim on YouTube we
can do a counter claim and have their
claim pushed back they can then in 10
within 10 days file a lawsuit otherwise
YouTube restores our video they then
have to sue us but if if if this is
allowed to stand what happens is you
have Democrat and Republican the
Democrats run criticism of the GOP and
let's say Democrat personalities and
Republican personalities are commenting
and criticizing and then large
institution whoever it may be can choose
to only strike certain PL channels the
other the people who are not given a
strike can't sue and the people who are
given a strike don't have standing in
court to argue oh but look they're not
being taken down because the argument is
okay well we'll go take them take them
take them down next you would have that
argument you could say they're doing
this selectively but what what the
situation that creates is the only
person with the power is the institution
controlling the debates no one can fact
check and comment on it and they can
control who's allowed to fact check and
commented on it that that's that's an
possibility but I've got more news here
to add to this David Pacman 9 days ago
has uh had announced the same thing and
I was unaware of this and uh here you
can see the copyright strike he received
on his channel let me remove the uh uh
remove the copy uh the the CC the Clos
captions you can see that uh it no way
does it affect his ability to stream as
of right now Fox Media LLC October 6
filed the strike against them I can say
this now I'm not going to reveal uh any
P any what here's what I can say several
other uh uh individuals who were
providing commentary on uh uh on the
debates also received strikes and had
their commentary taken down it's hard to
know when you know we started doing a
curs research of other channels because
the videos aren't there so we don't know
if they did or didn't I don't track what
everybody does but uh knowing that David
did I immediately saw this video when I
started doing my my search of this and
David also received a strike so we'll
see what happens over the next week or
so don't know I I I I would be I would
be shocked if Fox News actually tries to
pursue lawsuits against a combined you
know 50 million subscribers across the
board arguing that they are the only
ones allowed to have commentary I will
further add in my view and uh probably
if there was going to be a suit you know
my lawyers going be like stop saying all
this stuff I don't care this is
important the show that we did is not
even a substitute for what Fox was
providing no you could not even hear the
de half the time because we are just
insulting
politicians if you want to actually just
listen to the words of the politicians
you go you go watch the debate on Fox
News if you want to hear us yell at them
and insult them you come here but you're
not even hearing half the time what what
they were saying so I don't even think
that argument stands Fox News is
deciding to go to war against some of
the biggest political commentators in
the world right now I can't imagine they
I think this is I think this is an abuse
of the system and uh I think they lose
on this on this one this is insane and
this is why you know initially we didn't
even want to do uh uh the coverage of it
because it's stupid because the Lesser
known Republican candidates Trump is
going to win and so we decided to simply
because uh you know ultimately there's
there's several things one people really
wanted to hear us fact check and comment
on what they were saying and so we
they're like look they didn't care what
what was being shown in the debates they
cared what we were how we were
responding how essentially we want to
debate the presidential candidates if
Fox News has their way there will be no
public debate on our presidential
candidates and I think that's that's
absurd it's like a reaction video too I
I I I can I can respect to a certain
degree an argument made by Fox but I
think it's a bad argument that loses
because in order for us to have our
institutions our our El our
constitutional republic with Democratic
institutions there must be a robust
public debate on our are political
candidates and they do not have the
argument that they own the Monopoly on
the political debate if their show was
simply truckers arguing truck driving
totally get it but these people want to
be president and fox is telling me I
have no right to fact check them in real
time no way yeah it's no go ahead no
they they even went to the extent where
you said that they had a choice where
they could just take the video down or
actually like punish you with a strike
and they chose to punish you with a
strike so that just kind of goes to show
that it was you know kind of a
weaponized uh attempt to take a stab at
Tim pool for well it's not just me I
mean there's a bunch of it's a bunch of
people who got strikes they went after
they're going after everybody is my
understanding uh well I shouldn't say
everybody they've gone after a lot of
people I do have some questions because
I I can say they didn't go after
everyone just yet so I I say just yet
but that's the point if Fox News News is
selectively taking down only some then
the argument would be they are creating
an environment where any Institution
that is hosting a debate can choose
who's allowed to comment on the debate
well we can't have that there's there's
there's no functioning democratic
election if large institutions are like
we're going to let these seven people do
it I mean I mean this I I'll put it this
way Fox could quite literally be like oh
all of those uh commentators we give
them a license those ones we take down
and it's and it's and it's arbitrary it
effectively just silos and manipulates
and controls public discourse I think
this is a a gross infringement an
egregious abuse of the system but I also
think I think if they pursue a lawsuit
it goes to the Supreme Court I think
they lose I also think that it doesn't
make any sense for Fox to be able to
have a
proprietary um broadcast there should be
anyone who wants to broadcast the debate
should be allowed in to broadcast the
debate that is in the public interest
it's a it's like you were saying these
are people who want to be president now
none of them are going to be president
but they certain you know but they're
certainly out there trying to do this um
and any American should have the ability
to to see that and the fact that Fox
News is on cable and a lot of people
can't see that also as a problem but
it's free online and there's a lot of
arguments they can make about who they
allowed to stream and things like that
don't care my argument is they want to
create a world where they are the funnel
of information on public discourse so
there's we have these things called
anti-s slap laws uh it's slap means
strategic lawsuit against public
participation Mo there are many states
probably half the country where if I
said David Pacman you know is a you know
leftist communist or whatever insult you
know insult him in some way then he
can't sue me for several reasons it's
not just the higher standards right you
could actually because David Pacman is a
public figure accuse him of doing a
backflip and landing in the mud and let
let's let's argue that for some reason
it's disparaging I'm trying I'm not
trying to dispar David I'm just doing as
an example because we pulled this
channel up uh anti-ap laws basically
shut the lawsuit down instantly arguing
that my accusations against them are
public participation that we are public
figures having a debate in public and we
are allowed to and so it's you you have
what's called uh times V Sullivan that's
where if I said someone is a uh uh if I
said Carter Banks kicked a dog he can't
sue me it's it's crazy because the the
the uh actual malice standard based on
the president of what's called time V
Sullivan he would have to prove I
intentionally lied knowing beforehand he
did not kick a dog which is almost
impossible because you You' you'd have
to get past summary dis summary judgment
get to Discovery nowhere to find the
statements and hope they are let's say I
know for a fact that Carter behind the
scenes was going Mah I'm gonna lie about
Tim p and claim he kicked a dog and then
I'm like I know he did it I heard him
say it can you prove it no but he said
it too bad you're outout now you get
that that's that's that's times V
Sullivan most people are familiar with
that that's how the left is able to call
everyone Nazis and white supremacists
they call Laura lummer a white
nationalist over Jimmy Kimmel just did I
mean that that may be defamation per se
I think she should sue because she
doesn't need to prove damages in that
case right defamation per se is when
you're accusing someone of something so
egregious that it in and of itself is is
damaging anti-s slap would then be if I
claim Jimmy kibble kicked a dog he and
he sued me over that then it'd probably
get thrown out instantly over anti- slap
there are a lot of states that are just
like nope you can't there he's talking
about public stuff that's going on when
I look at this I see something very
similar I think this needs to be handled
by the Supreme Court it must be and the
reason for it is the the era of the
ubiquitous live stream is new it has not
yet been adjudicated uh it has not yet
gone to the courts we need to know where
the Supreme Court stands on our right to
debate the political candidates in real
time when a when it when a candidate
stands on stage and says when I was
governor I did this and when I'm
president I'll do that and we go whoa
whoa whoa he didn't do that when he was
governor if there is no public debate
allowed then only wealthy institutions
are allowed to to to control who's who's
being president it destroys public
participation in debates so that's where
I stand uh rant over I guess but uh we
we will have some developments in the
next week or so as to what happens and I
think if Fox News does decide to take
this to
court here's what I ultimately think I
think Fox News will not I think they're
going to Cave they're going to back down
and they're going to accept it because
if Fox News does Sue this will go to the
Supreme Court and they will lose and
then it becomes precedent in law and
they'll never have a leg to stand in
again the best thing I think that needs
to happen frankly I think it needs to be
at the Supreme Court level so there's
only there's there's only uh uh two ways
that can happen the first is that Fox
News files a full full-fledged lawsuit
against the people who who commented I'm
willing to bet they won't do it because
they know it opens the door to defeat
and it opens the door to them never
having any ability to make an argument
on proprietary rights again the other
way would be if they overstep their
bounds and file multiple strikes against
a single individual giving them damages
and standing to a massive degree which
result in a lawsuit being filed against
them right in which case they it goes to
scotus they lose that whole process
could take a couple years but Fox will
be destroyed by it and they're already
not doing so great after the Dominion
lawsuit no right right they're they're
the the best thing for Fox to do is
certainly not this I would I would argue
the best the smartest thing Fox could do
was actually try and negotiate with
anyone who wants to do any kind of
commentary some propri some some some
like rights or distribution uh or some
monetization package or almost like a
press pass right I was just thinking
that like an e press pass yeah I think I
think Fox should make the AR so if if
this goes I think they lose outright we
have a right to to uh uh call out
politicians who are trying to be
president and they Fox News should not
have the the unilateral control over
that it's one thing if the argument was
we should have public cameras in those
debates and Fox News shouldn't be
allowed to have proprietary stream of
these things I don't know about that my
argument is our show was not a
substitute we were talking over the
politicians half the time you couldn't
you could barely hear what they were
saying right we didn't even have the
stream on their channel the whole time
and we were actively checking and
commenting I think they lose that one
the smartest move they could make right
now would be to go to all the channels
and say how about you give us ad rights
when you do it that way we don't get
into a lawsuit right if they go this
route the first strike received by David
by me and many others who have gotten
strikes has no impact whatsoever on the
channel the second strike takes you off
the air for 90 days we're
talking between all these channels I
don't know what $50 to100 million in in
potential damages yeah that's a lot of D
I don't know if Fox News wants to handle
another one of these lawsuits and I
don't know if they can handle a lawsuit
from 15 multi-millionaire industry
Network individuals I mean this is an
insane thing they're trying to do right
now I think also there's like a free
speech consideration that's so important
you know we have the right to comment
and discuss those who are running for
president and we certainly have the
right to do that in real time right we
were talking about the bar situation
before like you have like the debate on
at a bar and people come buy drinks to
and they watch it and they do they do
right so they're making money from the
debates you can't really I mean that
would be this is why I think uh this
would need to go to uh scotus it this is
a this is a federal level issue um
during the debates I can tell you
definitively and everybody knows bars
and other venues have the debate on you
go to a bar the news is playing now
their argument is yes but we buy cable
you know and so we can play the these
things on our TVs sure but what they're
doing now is I didn't charge any money
for anyone to come and watch the show
the show was just us commenting on the
news so that means all of these venues
that are playing the debate and talking
to people about it they're going to
argue that's copyright
infringement right or like you know when
you show movies you're not supposed to
show movies publicly they always put
that thing at the beginning like this is
not for public distribution but it
doesn't make that's totally different
because that's and that's totally
different because that is an
entertainment that is an entertainment
that was created by whatever you know
Studio or entity makes the entertainment
a presidential debate is not an
entertainment it's a it's a public
service it's something that voters in a
lot of ways voters demand because we
want to know what our you know WN to be
elected leaders because they're the
voters they're the voters they we want
to know what they want to do to our
country we want to know what they have
to say about um the state of the nation
and and what should be happening and uh
I think that that should get out to as
many people as possible as want to see
it yep they uh uh Fox News had issued a
memo saying that they would go after
anybody who did this and we know that
and I will say it plainly here we have
asserted since the beginning they have
no right to make this claim it is
absolutely fair use what people need to
understand is fair use is copyright
infringement but it has an exemption an
exception in the law so typically what
happens because I've dealt with this
quite a bit is that um when you infringe
on someone so when you when you engage
in what you would believe is fair use
you have infringed a copyright the
argument is then will a judge agree that
this is in the public interest in some
way and we know that the typical grounds
for fair use they're not absolute so one
thing people often like to say is the
length of uh uh the content maybe but
not always uh Saron of a of aad Carl
Benjamin famously uploaded a a clip from
a Kila
Hughes without comment without the video
was just a rip of her video reuploaded
she made the argument it was
infringement because he didn't transform
it he didn't comment on it he didn't do
anything Carl said you are incorrect the
title of the video itself was commentary
and thus it is fair use she sued him not
only did she lose she lost the
subsequent filing where she had to pay
him I think it was $100,000 y pound in
Fe pounds um was it no no no it was
dollars it was United States oh really
it was she sued him in the United States
okay and uh Carl won because
uploading I I I don't know if it was the
entirety of the video I think it was
several minutes I think it was like five
minutes and it was just a rip from her
channel cluded the video and she says
that's not fair use it was simply
because he put a title that said like it
was titled something like the absolute
mental state of the left or something
like this that's all it took I would the
issue here a lot of people make these
arguments we're talking about people who
want to be president who who are live
real time lying misrepresenting facts
and saying things that need to be fact
checked by journalists and this is the
modern era news is presented in this
format it is no longer a world where you
know we didn't sneak a camera into Fox
News and then and broadcast it that's
that's essentially their argument is
predicated upon an old school era where
someone recaptures their stream and
reposts it whereas we were actually
engaging in public discourse that's
something that's going on in a lot of
law right now like we just saw this
Douglas Mackey case yes uh Ricky Rick
Ricky vaugh from 2016 and he had posted
memes leading up to the 2016 election
joking around that Hillary Clinton
voters should uh text their vote for
Hillary Clinton and the joke of course
it's basically a political cartoon right
which is a point that uh Jack pic and
Gavin wax were making the other day on H
Jack show but it's that's essentially
what it is it's a it's a political
cartoon and the idea is that um he was
he was making the joke that Hillary
Clinton voters aren't smart enough to
know whether or not they could vote by
text message now of course as it turns
out in the trial yeah in the trial
against him uh it turned out that the
Department of Justice could not prove
that anyone was harmed At All by this
joke no one voted by text um because as
a result of this meme that he posted yet
the Department of Justice and the FBI
investigated the meme which was vote for
Hillary Clinton by text you know um it
was like it was like vote from home text
here or something right right right and
it was like and so the Department of
Justice uh and the FBI the FBI
investigated the Department of Justice
alleged that it was an ad not a meme not
a joke do you remember the Democrat
woman who did the same thing yeah the
Democrat woman did the same thing we
documented that every time we've covered
it at post millennial we document and a
Democrat did the exact same thing saying
that Trump voters should vote by text
message that woman was not prosecuted
she was not investigated by the FBI uh
Douglas Mackey was he was convicted
seven months there it is we have this
from the post millennial she said hey
Trump supporters skip poll lines at
election 2016 and text in your vote text
votes are legit or vote tomorrow on
super Wednesday so texla votes are uh
text votes are legit should have put her
in criminal territory relative to what
this guy did and there's his too this
one just says avoid the line vote from
home text Hillary I'm with her go
Hillary and it's a a meme it's a joke
it's and and the funny thing is this is
202 when when did when did he post that
that was uh that was 2016 but it was it
was it after hers uh I don't know I
don't know the she said text votes are
legit right I suppose the argument is
she didn't include a number to call or
did
she cuz it's a video there there's a
video but the video was taken down which
is why we have that which is why we just
have a her
screenshot um
but yeah so he posted this the
Department of Justice claimed that it
was an ad instead and didn't acknowledge
that it was a meme accused him of
conspiracy against rights which is of
course what Donald Trump is being
accused of by the doj right now over
January 6th he was convicted of
essentially election interference and
he's supposed to spend seven months in
prison over this uh we actually got a
message from a fact Checker today being
like can you provide any evidence for
your claim that he was he's being
sentenced to 7 months in prison over a
meme and it's like why yes we can
provide all of the documentation that we
have as well as the Department of
Justice press release about the
conviction in the first place that says
he posted this ad and it was
investigated by the FBI um it's
absolutely insane but it's another first
rights issue uh First Amendment rights
issue and we have had so many of these
recently we see in the cases against
Donald Trump where he's being slapped
with gag orders he's not allowed to
speak publicly about various elements of
the case and it's basically because the
prosecutors don't like getting made fun
of on Truth social that's the issue they
don't like that they feel you know they
feel
insulted when did they actually file
this because it was from the 2016
election oh it was from the 2016
election it's a meme about it but does
it say they didn't even file a complaint
until 2021 so they waited until after
2020 to go after him like after the
whole election stuff that went on with
Trump oh for something it didn't even
affect the 2016 election they punished
him for the 22 or the 2020 election
which is interesting which is dangerous
too which means they're hunting people
down from the old school Trump era
people that helped Trump get elected the
first time they're going after them even
now it's also like out of Pardon
territory like just just in case
yep yeah it was USA Today that reached
out to us but what um let's see when did
they do it they just they just spoke
about the
sentencing uh and they said that uh no
they said um as proven at trial by 2016
Mackey had established an audience on
Twitter with approximately 58,000
followers a February 2016 analysis by
the MIT media lab ranked Mackey as one
of the most significant influencers on
the then upcoming presidential election
uh so they were using that against him
like the fact that he had a platform the
fact that he had a lot of followers
platform followers follow him because he
makes memes probably because he makes
memes would they be voting for for
Hillary by tax right yeah it's a bad
argument and we had to explain the joke
to the fact Checker we had to be like
the joke was but these are ENT I mean
these are contemporary political
cartoons that's what's going on here
right so the point is this guy's
followers are not voting for Hillary at
all right right exactly well he need go
to jail and now he's going to go to jail
what they uh they said
um for example on November 1st 2016 in
or around the same time that Mackey was
sending Tweets suggesting the importance
of limiting black turnout so they're
using a racial thing the defendant
tweeted an image depicting an
African-American woman standing in front
of an African-American for Hillary sign
the ad stated avoid the line vote from
home um and they say that that's
deceptive and they're using that racial
thing as though that like somehow makes
it kind like a different argument than
the one that they're trying to use it's
exactly yeah so yeah H and then they
they complain that he also tweeted the
same image in
Spanish but I mean that's actually kind
of funny maybe the only one they have
it's amusing yeah you know it's
amusing so um yeah I think what is
happening to timcast over this Fox News
thing that's definitely a 1A thing well
I was thinking about smacky thing if you
just muted the video and had the
transcript it would be like 80% it would
be you could not even get the debate
through that it would be mostly
commentary and jumbled words around I
mean you wouldn't be able to yeah like
not the same thing at all yeah the trans
what we said yeah right yeah definitely
cuz we and the people who are like I
can't hear what they're saying I'm like
then go watch the debate I guess yeah
yeah we can just go turn on ABC yourself
you know the same but this this thing
with Douglas Mack Macky is a whole whole
another thing I mean it's it 2024 is
going to get nuts uh I I I strongly
recommend everybody watch this morning's
culture War if you did not you need to
it was with Dr Robert Epstein and Robert
Bose and we were discussing uh mostly it
was Dr Epstein discussing what what
Google does and you got to watch it two
hours of him breaking down how Google's
cheating yep Google's cheating on the
election well so uh it's really really
simple he said that they have hard Data
Tracking this admissible in court
provable on Election Day 100% of
democrat voters get a notification go
vote really and Republic 59% of
Republicans get the same thing that is
enough it doesn't matter uh and I think
I think that may have been Facebook one
of the big tech companies had done
something like this it doesn't matter if
they control what you what you see or
hear all that matters is they remind you
on the day of Republicans get don't
forget to go buy pizza and wings today
don't miss out on the new uh
imagine this it's election day and you
wake up in the morning you're like am I
forgetting something and you look at
your phone and you're a trump supporter
and it says major discount at Wings you
know Wing store and huge party available
get you know 10-cent wings today and
you're like whoa you call your buddies
like hey man they got 10-cent Wings we
should go hang out and you know and
watch the game and like let's let's go
and totally forgetting his election day
and the Democrats wake up and look at
their phone and it says go and vote
right now and they go oh that's right
voting today
all takes if they can get 5% of
Republicans not to vote by doing
something like that it's done yeah
that's enough yep and between that and
the Intensive suppression that there was
in 2020 of anything that would indicate
Joe Biden was a giant liar with a
history of family corruption right you
know true okay so they were putting ads
on social media like reminding Democrats
to go out and vot call ADS what were
they like notification from Facebook
it's
like yeah when when when when you go on
Facebook you've never gotten these uh I
yeah I have I have gotten but like it
was like yeah I guess you're right but
they were targeting mostly Democrats
what he was saying is that I don't know
if it was face which platform he
mentioned did this but he said Democrats
when 100% of the Democrats in their
study got notifications to go vote and
only 59% of Republicans did interesting
yeah that's all it takes and then there
there's of course the the the
information manipulation which everyone
is mostly focused on but you got to
understand how simple it is now the
interesting thing is he
said when Ted Cruz filed a letter
basically calling uh I think calling
Google out for this he said we watched
in Georgia the mechanism by which the
bias is created turn off they're
tracking what he said were eph what they
call ephemeral experiences and this is
crazy this is crazy stuff here's how it
works everything you do online mostly
recordable and tracked you post a tweet
someone can archive it however the
Google results that you get will never
be repeated you get that one time that
image that you see on that page is not
stored or archived anywhere and it's
gone in a moment really yeah yeah I mean
it wouldn't be stored no but yeah I I
remember realizing how crazy it is that
my Google search results for the exact
same Search terms were different than
somebody else's and they'll be different
for you the next time you do it yeah and
so with that why is that why did he say
that was so well that's just the nature
by which Google operates when you search
the algorithm will generate a list of
possibilities and if you search again it
may change this is
why because these things are ephemeral
what happens is
Google I suppose the argument is they
can you can search for Donald Trump
Google can send you the most insane
things ever Trump is Hitler Trump is
evil and you're like oh my oh my God no
one saw that it that it happened you
will never see it again and you can't
prove it so they thought thought this
data is not being tracked but it's
manipulating people's perspectives
perception so what he started doing what
what they do now is they have a whole
bunch of volunteers tens of thousands I
think 12,000 or whatever and they
actually track all the searches and
everything everyone's seeing and they've
actually created a database proving the
bias and track tracking it in real time
so when Ted crew sent this letter he
watched the lopsidedness of Democrats
being given positive information
Republicans being you know negative
information then Ted crw sends a letter
and it's gone
and I think Zack Vorhees a whistleblower
who came out to Veritas uh made a
similar AR s b gu right yeah it's on
your made a similar similar argument
that Google can turn it off and on and
manipulate elections and all that so
yeah
that's next what happens they pick what
goes at the top and you can't tell me
they don't
because well it's really weird too is
uh Douglas Murray's Madness of crowds
has a whole chapter about how when you
type in like married couple it will show
you like two men and a baby or something
weird uh or or different interracial
couples yeah yeah it's kind of like
agenda driven in the yeah you think you
think I haven't seen a commercial with
all white people in it since the
Canadian suicide commercials like oh and
the Army ones recently are coming out
they're white but there is absolutely an
agenda behind everything because radical
leftist run Silicon Valley they run run
the big Tech Industries they run pretty
much everything that's why it was so
important when Elon Musk took over
Twitter it was like one of our guys like
taking over like a giant uh and kind of
leveling the playing field and that's
what we have to do we have to continue
to build we have to continue to start
like a hostile takeover of these tech
companies well or the parallel economy
which I think is so great you know to
see alternative ways like you know um
the company that Tim was just
highlighting at the top the cool Wood
Products don't don't buy them from Ikea
buy them from this guy you know I think
that's a that's a better way to go I was
recently um so I travel a lot for work
and I was walking down the uh whatever
you call it the jetway to get onto the
plane and you're standing there waiting
to get on the plane and it's just all
advertisements of you know why our
Airline is the best one and there was an
interracial couple there was a gay
couple there were like all of these um
alter everyone who was in it was sort of
like alternative to the what you would
traditionally have seen like the more
stereotypical thing and I was like it's
it's just so obviously intentionally
done you know these changes that are
being made to affect our impression um
and I think that it's true like I saw
this recently it was like um most of
these ads are geared toward middle-aged
white women yeah definitely that's who
are like all on SSR
anyway Disturbed the general marketing
idea that so uh you you'll see a lot of
these commercials where it's an
interracial couple couple with mixed
race kids and there's a lot of people
who think it's a conspiracy to uh uh uh
like get white people to stop having
kids or something or to you know mix
Race date or something like that no it's
actually really simple because I know a
bunch of marketing guys and when this
before this stuff even started happening
the conversation was occurring in these
rooms marketing rooms they're basically
saying we have a marketing budget of $10
million we need to hit these
demographics and they'd be like okay
what's our what's our strategy for
selling you know insert product in the
white neighborhoods of Detroit what's
our strategy for black neighborhoods and
then Millennial the brilliant Millennial
goes why don't we just have like a black
wife and a white husband because then
you can sell to the black neighborhood
and the white neighborhood and they were
like that's a good point we can save
costs by doing one commercial if we show
a black person and a white person in the
same shot enjoying a meal with our
product and they're like that's a great
idea and it doesn't work the exact
opposite happens it becomes relatable to
no one but that that that was that was a
lot of the mentality of these marketing
firms was right like how can we minimize
the cost of production and maximize our
reach they thought white Liberals are
going to eat this stuff up and it'll
play really well in minority communities
because you know interracial couples and
it's like bro interracial people are
like 3% of this country yeah you have
just dramatically removed yourself from
what people would relate to right I'm
I'm sorry that it's true people just
forget that it's like it's a budget
thing it's not has it has mainly to do
with saving money it's like more
effective seem well intentioned but not
thought through it's not going to work
on on paper even though on paper it
looks like it does work in reality it's
not going to work in practice it doesn't
work look at Victoria's Secret they
switch fascinating right great example
so they got rid of the Angels the sexy
women in lingerie 2018 is uh yeah
20221 yeah they put Megan rapo in y and
some fat women and they were like this
is what women a lot of trans a lot of
men advertising women's remember Calvin
Klein had big morbidly obese people yeah
and so the are and and if you go to uh
the mall you'll see their models are
just morbidly obese and they have
morbidly obese mannequins the argument
being made was this is more
representative so we're trying to Target
real women right well why why do this
you know these these sexy models women
don't aren't like that they want to see
real people these these these marketing
people are dumb as a box of rocks yeah
it's kind of true that's someone who has
a marketing degree went through a
marketing at like a big school in the
United States most people that are in
marketing are there because they dad
told them to or they just don't know
what they're going in school they're not
really in it for the for the thing
Victoria Secret reverts and goes back to
sexy women realizing that okay that
didn't work and I think we'll see a lot
of the same thing in advertisements
they're going to say okay definely you
know like look this area in this city is
is 90% white and we're trying to sell
them a product they're we we want them
to think that's me and I should use that
product so if you create an experience
to them that is more foreign L
figuratively and literally then that's
that's not resonating with them yeah it
doesn't resonate with me I remember
seeing the uh I remember seeing the ads
of like men wearing
lingerie yeah and like it's like trans
people in lingerie or like very large
women in lingerie or even just in
regular clothes uh seeing Dylan mulany
in a Kate Spade dress like I'm never
going to buy that dress when I look at
clothes I don't know about you Lauren
but when I look at clothes and I think
like oh it looks great on that person
and then you sort of have this in your
mind like if I buy that I will look
great too you don't want to see how bad
the clothes look on really fat people
because then you look at it and you're
like oh I'm going to look fat in it too
exactly I'm not looking at an extra
large person thinking yeah I need that I
need to look just like that but it was
crazy but it was also what was but
obviously there was agenda an agenda
behind it because they can not expect
that to like increase sales you know if
we put extra-large very offensive
looking people in our clothes like how
this is not going to increase sales
which brings you back to the agenda it's
all about the agenda the agenda that oh
um obesity is beautiful oh to be um you
know way overweight and unhealthy that's
how you need to be in order to get the
spread in Victoria Secret same with
Dylan malany you know if you are a male
who decides to dress as a a be a dress
as a woman hey you get a Bud Light deal
you got a Tampax deal he got everything
under he got a tack deal he did he got a
t that's yes so ridiculous so I think
what we're seeing now is all of these
women liberal women claiming they
believe these things have been lying the
whole time and Victoria Secret is proof
the proof is sales declined hey hey hold
on Victoria's Secret didn't didn't pull
a Bud Light I mean they kind of did but
there was no big boycott no big backlash
women didn't go around saying no more
Victoria Secret they just silently
stopped buying it just stopped buying it
while cheering for it these liberal
leftist women were like Yay I'm not
buying that and what does it
show the what I what what here's how I
think it works the beautiful women that
you see in lingerie women are like I
understand that women is objectively
beautiful I want to be objectively
beautiful like her I want to wear what
she's wearing and be objectively
beautiful but when you put morbidly
obese women and people like Megan rapo
who is look not beautiful she's a great
athlete props to her and all that but
she is not what men typically and
stereotypically are attracted to and May
and she doesn't want that that's fine
for her I'm not arguing anything I'm
just saying you're women then look at
Megan R rapo and go she is not
objectively beautiful I do not want to
look like her stops buying the product
clothes are aspirational you know you
buy clothes because you want them to
make you look good and you want to make
you want to feel good how you're part of
whatever the beautiful thing is how many
women buy one size smaller because
they're like I'm going to fit in this I
literally never do that no but but I'm
I'm saying I'm not saying the majority
women it I'm saying it will never happen
there there there are that just makes me
feel worse wishful thinking looking at
Victoria's Secret models okay well like
I'm not a woman but uh my assumption is
the reason why we have movies where the
dudes are massive like you know uh uh
Chris Chris Hemsworth in Thor for
instance that you always see these
stories where uh actually Jason uh Jason
Mamoa mom his
namea Lisa bonet's ex-husband they they
they posted a photo of him at the beach
and they were like he's looking pretty
fat he wasn't it's just that he
dehydrates himself so that his skin gets
real thin you can see his muscles so he
looks ripped but then when he starts
drinking water again dehydration oh yeah
so when you see men in movies and
they're looking all ripped and their
veins are
mus and they're like they don't drink
water for days oh awful that's so awful
I would much rather have a hydrated
puffy guy yep and then and and then
you'll see like it looks like love
handles but it's it's it's thick skin
and they have some fat on their body but
to get in shape for the movie they eat
ridiculous amounts of Fish and Chicken
all day every day work out relentlessly
and then dehydrate right before they
film the scene for like three days yeah
the reason we go to those extremes is
because you're trying trying to create
something beyond the normal something
aspirational that looks like a heroic
very very strong man I imagine it's
similar in in a certain way for women
with like Victoria Secret and these
other companies they're they say we all
know that men and women find that
beautiful and we want to be as beautiful
as we can be so we want to be like them
that's why I think the sales drop when
they put morbidly obese women cuz like
well there's a bunch of fat women they
don't want to look like that no they
want to look like supermodels they want
they want to improve themselves and be
better they want to look better and be
more attractive men want to look better
and be more attractive men want to do
more pull-ups or whatever but then you
see it all fall apart right and also I
think like for example with Victoria's
Secret like guys buy stuff for their
like wives and girlfriends and stuff
like and they're looking at Big
Bonquisha over there I don't know about
that so like they want like the
goodlooking stuff cuz a lot of men buy
stuff for their girls too and they about
that that's a really good point too the
guy walks to the mall and he's like I
want to like my wife you know I want to
get her something nice and they're take
a look at this and there's like a 300 lb
morbidly obese mannequin they're just
like she would take this as an insult
like you can't do that let's uh let's
talk about this story here from The
Daily Mail conspiracy theorist Alex
Jones must still pay 1 billion in
Damages to Sanuk families and can't hide
behind his bankruptcy protection judge
rules this is crazy they are saying that
bankruptcy is not enough so the general
idea of the bank of a bankruptcy is hey
we need to prioritize what we're paying
back to keep the company operating if
they begin to seize his assets Infowars
will cease to exist that was always the
point I'm not surprised this is
happening it's going to get a lot worse
in 2024 they're going to start going
after
everybody
yeah there's kind of part of it with the
whole YouTube thing it's going to start
happen yeah it's all going to start
happening this is different from you
know Fox what the thing about Fox News
and the and the strike I think this is
just something that needs to be uh the
president has not been set on a new
technology and a change in how the
public operates right so this is one of
the first elections where you have
ubiquitous live streams with prominent
personalities who dominate prime time so
of course the argument from fox is like
hey what do you think you're doing and
it's like welcome to the new world of
public participation this technology
exists people have always played the
debates and argued and debated them and
fact checked them to the public now it's
happening in digital world right if Fox
News has their way it reverses the
internet I you know hey maybe then
there's no Liv in the pot the bugs
because you can't have digital broadcast
and dig digital public debate they'd get
rid of it this is different Alex Jones's
opinions 10 years ago he had very bad
ones he's got to pay a billion dollars
okay fine he lost they had a some right
judgment against him he files for
bankruptcy this will destroy the company
it'll get all my employees fired and the
judge says so what this is lawfare this
is they are trying to destroy Alex Jones
and you know you had talked earlier like
said earlier about like defamation
lawsuits now they have to be said in
Malice and I truly don't believe he said
those things in Malice back then you
know what I'm saying I think he truly
believed them back then and clarify
actual malice means you intentionally
lied you knew what you were saying was
false yeah so you say something
intentionally knowing it was false so it
absolutely is cuz like a lot of us like
we there's lot of like misinformation
there's a lot of stuffff out there like
we say things we see things and we make
you know a statement believing it at the
time he didn't say that in Malice like
he truly believed what he was saying at
the time and now they're still coming
after him 10 years later even though and
he never even said anything like Alex
Jones never said anything that stated oh
yeah I knew it wasn't true and I said it
anyway so it really is just a continued
weaponization of the justice system to
shut down all descent to shut down
digital media cuz they're coming for you
next cuz cable television is dying and
digital is the future and anybody who
has a name for themselves or makes some
really good points or actually does some
damage on culture taking back the
culture they're going to try and come
for you so that's just what they do so
you have to you know and
honestly apologizing to they come after
you when you start apologizing they
smell blood you never apologize never
they smell blood and they will you all
the way whole struggle session thing
don't apologize in a struggle session
yep just sit there and take it and leave
and that's true that's it why did they
say that he can't file for bankruptcy
and protect himself that way I mean I
assume the reason is arbitrary quote the
families are pleased with the court
ruling that Jones's malicious conduct
will find no Safe Harbor in the
bankruptcy court said Christopher M A
Connecticut lawyer as a result Jones
will continue to be accountable for his
actions on his site y yada I don't know
that seems absurd also where is he
supposed to get a billion dollars he
only has 14 million it's like saying we
know you don't have it but that's not
good enough right how is he supposed to
get it if they shut down his channel
that's the only way he makes money
because it's not what it's about yeah
exactly so they just want to Scuttle him
this is I think this proves it if it was
really about recovering damages they'd
say bankruptcy must protect Alex Jones
and then we will garnish whatever wages
and profit he would get off his show
right but if they're saying no
bankruptcy protection then infowar
ceases to exist and that's it end of
story no money for anybody yeah it's
kind of like an by any means possible
kind of thing is what I'm saying no
matter what whatever they can do I don't
know if it says what is explanation for
why bankruptcy doesn't apply uh at least
here it just says the judge said it so
it is I don't I don't know what the
argument is yeah and when was this ruled
was this today today really this just
happened today I knew that they like of
uh like initially were suing him for the
entire like it was like the same amount
as the military or something like like
the defense budg budget of the United
States something ridiculous and it was
you know I mean they're just trying to
take him down you know I hope Alex stays
strong we we're with you man like this
is not good um and they're just like
it's not even legal it's not legal what
they're doing and I hope he appeals it I
know that different states have
different um you know standards on how
much you can sue a person for so like in
the state of Connecticut like even
though it was in Connecticut in some
places like they couldn't sue him for
more than a certain amount
legally so I don't know if this still
applies to that or if that just
overrules all of that I have to read it
even CNN doesn't doesn't give the the
reasoning behind why he's not protected
from like bankruptcy no do this doesn't
make sense it just says the judge said
it the familyes filed the motion because
they thought he wouldn't pay and then it
goes on to explain the the past lawsuit
I love the logic behind that we thought
we wouldn't pay it so we just charged
you a bunch more money millions and
millions more dollars well they're
saying we thought he wouldn't pay
because of the bankruptcy so he had we
want the judge to say he can't use
bankruptcy and the judge said okay oh
wow but it doesn't explain what the Jud
how the what the judg is uh uh why yeah
exactly why is this one bypassing
bankruptcy I still don't think the
family will get a single penny and it's
because if Jones goes if infow goes out
infow Wars is out of business there's no
money right yeah exactly most of the
most of the debt that cannot be
discharged in bankruptcy is child
support alimony unpaid taxes and student
loan debt most other things according to
Investopedia can be alleviated through
bankruptcy H yeah so I wonder what makes
this special yeah you know like what the
what the law is there and he fired filed
chapter 11 is that what he did or was it
yeah chapter 11 chapter
11 he says uh those uh okay so Lopez
ruled the protections do not apply over
findings of willful and malicious
conduct
oh that's another one here it is it says
Debs for debts for willful and malicious
injury to another person or property
willful and malicious here means
deliberate and without just cause and
that's um so that's one too deaths for
death or personal injury it was a
default ruling caused by the JY yeah
that doesn't seem there was no trial
over this yeah there was only there was
only a settlement hearing Jones never
actually got to argue any of his case
yep that does not seem uh that doesn't
seem how did we get to that point though
I mean look people keep saying oh you
know Civil War is a stupid thing to say
and it's like dude it's not just that
Trump has been indicted on like 91 or 94
counts it's not just that they've
arrested his lawyers it's not just that
uh a couple of his lawyers have just
been sentenced to five and six years of
probation for being his lawyers it's not
just that they're going after Alex Jones
in what is clearly going to destroy a
media outet uh and that he got no trial
for it it's not just
that Donald Trump was found in a summary
judgment to have committed fraud without
a trial in New York it's not just that a
judge said Donald Trump's properties are
worth a fraction of what they're
actually worth even to the protest of of
Finance experts and real estate experts
it is not just that they have been
targeting Trump supporters J Sixers
solitary confinement it's not just that
far leftists have received no penalty
for The Hundreds who stormed the capital
recently that light light slap on the
wrist it's not just that Ricky vaugh
Douglas Mackey gets seven seven months
seven months and a Democrat who did the
same thing gets nothing should the list
go on should the list go on it goes on
endlessly no I'm just saying there is so
much evidence that the machine is trying
to crush and destroy you for political
reasons to argue that we are not
entering one of the most dangerous times
in this country's history is ludicrous
and you'd have to forget
every every yesterday to believe we are
not headed towards something truly dark
now I kind of don't think we're losing
to be completely honest like I said
there's a lot of reasons to think that
we are winning but the desperation is
becoming palpable and I don't know to
what degree this goes it may just be
Trump wins and then oh there we go but
you guys watch the culture War episode
we did this morning I think it's Episode
34 it may be with Dr Robert Epstein as
he breaks down the machine of Google
Facebook big Tech and how they are
controlling what you think and they know
everything about what you're doing we've
talked about it Facebook can predict if
you're going to quit your job Facebook
can predict if you're going to go have a
bite to eat Facebook knows what
restaurant you're going to before you
even know because the the the algorithms
the AI knows all of the characteristics
about you and then it can formulate
these probabilities and know exactly
what you're going to do that's why when
you'll be you could be thinking
something and then you see an ad for it
and you didn't say it out loud and you
didn't say anything to anybody you're
just thinking it this is this freaky I
hate when that happens happens and it's
freaky people think that the reason an
ad will appear on Instagram like you're
talking with your buddy and you're like
you know I I I kind of think I need a TV
and then an ad appears like get a new TV
you're like yo it's spying on me it's
not predictive algorithms know more
about you than you know about yourself
now don't get me wrong they're spying on
you for sure and um if you have voice
activation on your phone your phone is
recording everything you say always
right because in order to activate it
has to be listening to you right mhm and
if you want your phone to activate
whenever you say your pass phrase then
it has to be listening all the time
waiting for that passphrase how does
voice activation work voice Tech works
by taking your voice sending it off to a
private company Translating that audio
file into a text file sending it back to
your device and then inputting that as
as a command which means everything you
say several famous stories where uh uh
there was a murder and an Amazon device
recorded the entire murder and they were
like we have the recording and people
are like how
in order to activate the Amazon device
it must be always recording yeah
otherwise how does it know when you say
those words it's like arguing that you
know you're you you plug your ears and
put on headphones so no one so you can't
hear anything but as soon as someone
says your name you'll take them off well
how you going to hear them say your name
if you're wearing ear ear muffs that's
the same thing with these these Amazon
and Google devices they are listening
247 welcome to your Brave New World yeah
so be careful in's houses when you're in
there at night stalking them trying to
you know injure them be careful that
Amazon be careful turn it off yeah but I
just think I think this Alex Jones story
I think next year is gonna get crazy
yeah definitely will I think we're going
to have to jump like vote Trump out of
prison what do you think do you think
we're going to get to that point I think
we're have to vote him out so he can
paron himself I'm ready to do it though
and that's Sydney Powell and Kenneth
Chase bro stabbing him in the back I
think that's definitely happening is is
going to result in uh widespread 14th
Amendment lawsuits in like every state
from every deal didn't she she did yeah
and so did chesboro and agreed to
testify against him and by pleading
pleading guilty what people keep saying
it's like it's so funny they're like
yeah but she she took misdemeanor
charges for election interfer like
interfering in off like an election or
something and Trump's name wasn't
mentioned and it's like okay okay yeah
headline guilty yes so now what's going
to happen is Trump's lawyer pleaded
guilty and has actually been sentenced
every Democrat you know Mark Elias
they're going to file 50,000 lawsuits
all saying in this court case in this
court case in this court case the the
the defendant admitted they interfered
they admitted and they were working for
Donald Trump directly and there's a
reason they keep charging the little guy
first there's a reason they charged all
the January 6 people in Tanya Chin's
court before they dragged Trump into her
court and the other thing too is you see
at Mara Lago in the documents case
um the they got the IT guy to flip on
Trump as well they got him a plea deal
and so he's going to testify as well
that he was I think I think they're
alleging that he had um been pressured
to erase surveillance
footage well see I think that they do a
lot of this too to get the headlines so
the headlines Trump's lawyer pleads
guilty to this election fraud like
election um uh manipulation or all these
different things to demoralize his Bas
cuz I know that Bas from 2020 truly
believes in the stop the steel movement
you know everything they March for
everything they were they truly believed
in it and it's a a way to demoralize
them as we go into 2024 like thinking am
I crazy like was I wrong for supporting
that movement and they do that with
those headlines so it's not just
chipping away at Trump it's chipping
away at his base to demoralize his base
and that's something important to know
like when they gave Sydney pow a plea
deal then they knew that would hurt that
would kind of hurt cuz she had a lot of
big supporters uh during the stop the
steel movement and she just you know
that was that was a hit and they're just
chipping away at him hoping that Trump
will give up you know that's the whole
thing if we indict him enough maybe
we'll get him to give up but every time
they do that his polling numbers go up
and it's just getting better and better
so you're right Tim it's going to be a
crazy year however it's going to be
brutal too because they won't stop
they're going to file insane lawsuits
yes it's it's just and and and they're
going to make the 14th Amendment
argument that he can't be president
check out this story we have in the
Daily Mail judge finds Trump $5,000 for
calling his clerk Schumer's girlfriend
and now deleted truth social post so you
me to tell me that after he was told to
shut up he retroactively then came back
and said okay now you got to pay me
money yeah so they made Trump be quiet
uh Trump deleted the post and now
they're finding him it says the judge
said it was a blatant violation of a gag
order prev ing Trump from publicly
attacking his staff did he call her
Schumer's girlfriend again I don't so I
don't think he did it again I think it
was just the one time was that a he
deleted it but it also appeared on his
campign website H right this was the old
post that I I thought that was the
pretext for the for the gag it was yeah
the he didn't he didn't want him uh
engoron is that how you say his name
engoron I guess uh did not want Trump
saying mean things about his staff okay
so that was the mean thing that caused
him to want a gag order yes and then
after the gag order he went back and is
now finding Trump for this post that he
had erased yeah because it looks like it
was also on his campaign website hey
this is just the beginning he's gonna
the I think the judges are going to do a
whole bunch of crazy stuff right they
can get they can lock Trump up right now
on
contempt that you don't you don't need a
reason for that they can he can come in
and and he can and Trump he can wait for
Trump to say anything hey watch your
tone with me if you do that that again
I'm going to hold you in contempt right
and then Trump says okay fine I I warned
you lock him up bayth they could play
whatever shady games they want now
granted he's got cameras in the
courtroom so he's trying to be a movie
star here because he's a psychopath but
uh we'll see how that plays out I just
think people many people on the right
Libertarians post- liberals Etc keep
thinking they're playing they're playing
a game of chess you know where it's like
okay well you know I know the rules you
know the rules you do the best move I'll
do the best move meanwhile they're
sitting back and they've got like five
queens and they're like What's that over
there and they put a queen on the board
and it's like how do you have two queens
it's like what do you
mean it's just normal yeah it's like
they changed the rul was last year you
can now have five Queens yeah what do
you mean last year we agreed we all
agreed yeah I mean why don't you have
five Queens oh that's too bad I win
right it's like playing Monopoly where
the person who's the banker keeps
pulling extra money out and you're like
you're cheating I'm like no I'm not yeah
guys we vot last ruled on this last turn
it's okay new rules guys
we he also has the gag order in the DC
case it was put on hold today for a
little bit but he also yeah it was what
you can put a gag order on hold for a
little bit Yeah so judge Tanya shutkin
who actually uh uh oversaw the cases of
a number of January 6 defendants and
sentenced them to longer than the
Department of Justice was even asking
for said that the gag order in that case
that's the j6 case would remain on hold
while she considers Trump's um
suggestion that he should be allowed to
speak freely about the
case what yeah so she had issued the gag
order on Monday which prevented him from
speaking publicly um by targeting
prosecutors or anyone on staff or
Witnesses wow and it's a very serious
restriction it's the most serious
restriction that they've had so far in
any of the cases Trump's attorneys um
appealed it and so now they're now
they're just like hanging on for a
minute Trump's lawyers called it
egregious and
intolerable saying by restricting
president Trump's Free Speech the gag
order eviscerates the rights of his
audiences including hundreds of millions
of American citizens who the court now
forbids from listening to president
Trump's thoughts on important issues
that's crazy that's actually a great
point it's only getting started and that
is what he says right like they're not
coming after me they're coming after you
I'm just in the way and Trump's BAS
loves those insults too like they love
they're a lot of fun they're funny
they're the best part I thought Trump's
tweets were the best part of trump and
they them trying to stop that you know
it's unacceptable and I love how like I
mean Biden keeps making everything worse
and worse and on Twitter people keep
going hey all wouldn't it be nice to
just have some Mean Tweets hey Mean
Tweets were the best part true it's true
yeah I mean their argument was but but
the Mean Tweets mhm and so you're like
no new Wars but the Mean Tweets
were withdrawing from the active Wars we
in but the Mean Tweets and then it's
just like a lot of people were like but
we like the Mean Tweets exactly they're
great and it's just because he was just
an ordinary person saying things that we
all were thinking and I thought like I
think my favorite one was like the the
Rosie O'Donald one and like she got
really mad and no was it Megan Kelly
asked him about it like cuz I think he
caught her like really insulting and she
was like oh you called women this and he
said no just Rosie and it was really
funny it was it was one of the epic
moments of trump um I think that's one
of our favorite Parts there's like whole
Shane Gill bit about how he just went up
there and started you know attacking
every was like whoa you can do this like
this is like they could be your thing he
like yeah it can be yeah and I'll give
it to Ted Cruz he was a good sport I'm
pretty sure like Trump told him like his
like wife was ugly or something and like
then he turned around lion's head oh
yeah he insulted him so bad but you know
what lion like Roar like lion like he
called him liing Ted and then after uh
like Ted got behind Trump all of the
Trump supporters start saying lie
in yeah yep yeah he was a good sport he
didn't hold he just stopped in line and
endorsed him it was good I actually Ted
Cruz I respected for that so I don't
know what the the Dan santis campaign
thinks they're doing I mean you but the
crazy like I keep hearing people we have
a lot of people come on the show and
we've had some people who are not
conservatives but they're kind of just
like come on guys we got to win this and
they're going why are the desis people
attacking me and I'm like what' you say
like I I haven't said anything about
them and I'm
like dude the desandis people are trying
to lose that's the only thing I can say
yeah what's amazing is they keep giving
ammunition to Joe Biden yeah maybe
that's the point I don't know yikes yeah
they uh see I liked d santis as a
governor I thought he was a great
Governor he did a great job during you
know coid and everything but it was just
the standard it wasn't like he was doing
like Superior things that like set apart
like that is what the standard should
have been governor should have kept
their states open they should have not
put masks on kids they shouldn't have
closed the schools down closed the
churches just because DeSantis didn't do
that doesn't make him special it means
he was upholding the standard and you
know I respect him doing that uh
especially because a lot of Republicans
sold out during that time however you
know it's a character flaw Donald Trump
drug him across the Finish Line in his
election to put him where he was and
this is how you treat them you know it
was I think that uh it was a a character
flaw on his behalf I think that um he
should remain Governor the people of
Florida need him and I don't think that
he needs to have higher aspirations at
least not
yet so that's my opinion on I thought he
could have been a shoe in for for the
next goor round you know yep he should
have been he should have been VP and
then Presidential candidate next time
around should have ran that that was the
path if he had ran on hey this is my
record this is what I've done this is
what um you know my conservative record
which is strong hey I'm just here cuz
Donald Trump might get arrested you know
like he was just running as like a the
high
he that's that's that's that's that's
campaign ending I missed this part of
the news cycle what happened with that
oh he's wearing lifts it's like that
Seinfeld episode remember where uh where
where they they said to the guy who was
like the the body double for one of the
kids on a TV show Mickey was Mickey and
they're like Mickey's wearing lifts he's
lifts in
yeah no don't and on Seinfeld he was
heightening because oh this was growing
what is this this definitely looks like
he's wearing lifts right here are they
just weird calul are those no because it
makes his his lower leg look really yeah
right like Chris angeling it weird it's
very weird yeah that's it there it is
too oh
man yeah that's damning for me like okay
so
look so there's no foot here in the
front of the boot and it's just like
dude yeah have you ever worn like Cowa
boots it looks like he's just putting
his foot halfway in his heel sitting
right on the on the end of the boot
right there you know what I mean like
but hold on he should really just look
how long his fibula is it's weird man
there's no way dude I don't know you can
argue that it's distorted or whatever
but I think when you can you can tell
there's no foot in the upper Boot and
the pressure on the front of the boot
looks like the top of his foot it does
this this it looks like an accurate
drawing of what he's doing yeah that's
what it looks like look how long his leg
would be if it was like yeah that's
crazy his leg would be massive dude this
guy just I don't know I feel bad for him
I feel bad for him because I thought he
did a good job yeah this looks like he's
on his tippy toes imagine halfway put on
your boot and going on national TV come
on bro yeah that'
be you can you can get away with doing
like a 2in heel lift inside your shoe
but whatever he's going for is just he
like standing his tippy toes man yeah
also like why do you need it well yeah
height height matters no question yeah
that much it matters that much yep
absolutely that's why what didn't didn't
someone want a box to stand on when
Trump they going to debate Trump or
something like
that Bloomberg yeah Bloomberg wanted a
box he is short as he's very not against
Trump though but in the debate he wanted
to box to because he's a little thing
but if you're open about it not tryde
it's when you try to hide it it's all a
numbers game and so the individual
doesn't matter you can come out and say
I know you're all reasonable right
they'll be like yeah but it doesn't
matter because if 1% of people factor in
height you lose so that's why uh uh
everybody everybody knows like the game
played by politicians and if you have
you guys ever seen that U movie The
Adjustment Bureau maybe uh it sounds
familiar it's fun fun movie with Matt
Damon where basically there's a bunch of
I guess you you call them Angels who
control people's destinies and are
guiding people and manipulating and so
this Matt Damon is running for Senate
and he loses and then they're like we
need to okay he lost that's good because
we want him to run again and win later
so they're like now we're going to get
him back on track they influence him he
goes out to give his concession speech
and then he just gets tired of it and
he's like okay and he just he's like see
this Tai we actually spent $5,000 to
figure out what the you know what tie I
should wear and he's like you know we
actually have a consultant telling us
what the right amount of scuff on a shoe
should be $15,000 like just basically
breaking it all down but that's the game
they play they probably went to panels
and showed Ronda speaking without the
lifts and with the lifts and found that
there was a massive benefit to wearing
lifted shoes lifted boots he's allegedly
wearing these things I believe it is
fair to say he is because it looks like
he's standing on a sippy toes in this
picture and his leg looks too long in
this picture looks like he's levitating
that it does like he's like leev it does
it funny it also doesn't help that you
can't even see the back of his foot yeah
I was looking at polls before like I
hopped on today and I think it's uh he
went down four points just today I was
wondering what happened not again I was
Hal beating him in in some in in one of
the latest polls and in the prediction
markets how great would it have been to
see him and Trump just like storm the
country you'd be like nice I don't you
know what I you know what I wonder I
wonder if they went to Dan santis and
told him to run to destroy him I'm not
kidding to destroy Dan santis yes Dan
santis was massively popular was pushing
a lot of anti-woke policies was look
look what happened to Florida under
under Dan santis he was the Shu and for
VP and we had talked about this I'm I'm
I'm hanging out in DC at National Harbor
and I hear a guy going like oh I can't
stand Trump man you know and then I was
like what about Dan santis like I could
vote Dan santis I could vote d s and I
said what if it was Trump Dan santis and
he's like ah yeah probably vote that I
heard so much of that if DeSantis was
the VP what did we all say oh it's no
question because as santis is the
Everyman The Regular Guy with military
experience who tones down Trump and
let's and gives you that Assurance don't
worry Trump I'm I'm gonna keep him in
check so they go to him and they whisper
in his ear now you should be president
come on run now who's Trump's VP do
santis implodes tanked his own I mean
come on who told him to wear those boots
whoever told him to wear those boots
destroyed him that's a really good point
because now he's disliked he used to be
loved now he's very disliked by the same
people that are that were wants his base
and that somebody was filling his head
telling him you got to run you're going
to win this we're going to make you like
the Superstar they loved you during Co
they're going to love you now and then
he ran and then it just crumbled from
there like and people just don't even
like him imagine a debate right I think
Trump should debate R should be on the
GOP debate stage oh yeah you know
because he's gonna be like show them
your boots R come on your Fe up and see
it you know he's wearing high
heels silly would he be able to amazing
that would be the best clip ever show
your boots Ron that's good and what's
Ron going to do I I I wonder because
I've been saying for a while it feels
like okay so so I'll explain this um I
posted something some somewhat innocuous
about Florida related to Jazz Jennings
all of a sudden the entire disantis
Communications team is insulting and
attacking me oh gosh I have friends
because Jazz was in Florida because Jazz
was in Florida and got surgery under Des
Administration and all I said was I said
where's where's Ronda santis the roate
response would be nothing say nothing if
you want to engage you could be like
here's the bill working on instead they
decided to get all of their
Communications people to call me a
an idiot other insults and I was like
what is this is crazy I'm like I've been
praising the guy for a year and then I
said one thing and they lose it I have
friends who worked in his campaign we
know that the disis campaign has an
explicit rule you do not go on timcast
IRL I've talked to some of these people
they're just like I'm like you you do
realize a bunch of prominent disantis
fans are asking me why you're insulting
them I'm not it's it's up to them to
speak out but the guests on this show
just go back through the list of the
people we've had on the show and you can
try and make your guess as to who you
think it is but it's about three people
have said are you being attacked by
Ronda sanz's campaign and then I'm like
I laugh about it I'm like oh they insult
me all the time and then they'll ask me
why is this happening we've had people
say I'm I've been getting attacked by
his Communications people for no reason
actually take a look at what happened
with Ashley
stclair past week this past week we did
uh she made a funny joke about Ron
wearing high heels and Christina Pusha
immediately responds like okay Christina
Pasha was like when you have no argument
against Ronda santz so you make up this
insult or whatever and it's like Ashley
posted a meme about boots she didn't
make an argument about policy she was
wasn't actually striking at his campaign
or his career or anything she was just
joking about a meme no I can't take and
immediately his Communications people
decide here's an opportunity to syn him
a few more points make us appear stodgy
ignorant and anyone in PR knows if
someone is highlighting say Ronda Santa
is wearing high heels the last thing you
want to do is pour gasoline on the fire
and announce it to your base it's
happening you say no no no everyone shut
up and let it blow over if you engage
with it you will make it a meme you will
make it public and you're fueling the
fire and look where we are now
especially asley because Ashley will now
find out for sure if he's wearing lifts
or not
well yeah yeah and yeah I mean she's
very diligent she will find out I can't
wait I me too so I I wonder
if when we were all praising Dan santis
and he was at the top of the prediction
markets beating Trump last year and we
were all like he's the guy then Trump
started coming back and picking up his
his speeches were getting better and
we're like I think it might be Trump and
everyone said I think it's Trump
DeSantis I'm willing to bet that the
never Trump or neocon said a trump
DeSantis ticket is unbeatable how can we
stop this let's throw money at DeSantis
and convince him he must run and he'll
win yep so they show all these polls
these prediction markets they whisper in
his ears you're the guy man you're the
heir it's not going to be Trump it's
going to be you and he goes you're I
should run destroys his relationship
with Trump the Trump base and now you
have fractured Maga people in Florida
who moved to Florida for dis santis
fervently love him so we had this event
in Miami we just about sold out um we
got to maybe like I think I think we
were short like we like 100 seats
available of 850 or something and one of
the one of the responses we got was for
a Miami event a lot of the people here
who would agree with these politics are
huge santis fans and so they're they're
like we don't want to come and watch
this because you guys rag Ona santis or
whatever they're fervent look if you're
willing to move from your state to
Florida because of Ronda santis you
don't want to be told youve backed the
wrong horse right so a lot of people are
just like no but imagine what it would
have been Trump Des STIs was unbeatable
and now what do we have Dan santis
wearing high heels yeah this is this is
worse than the yeaw remember who who is
that guy yeah and I'll tell you what I
don't see a single oh Howard de
that's right yeah that killed his
campaign ruined I had a friend working
on that campaign at the time and uh I
remember after the it was like a yop or
something like
that crazy and I called my friend and I
was like what the hell and he was like
no it's we're done we're done it's over
wasn't he leading yeah he was doing
great Dave Chelle did a thing like the
crazy I like heard about this and I
didn't even know the guy's name and I
just go like guy destroys his career
with a bad sound and he popped up and
really bad like yeah I see it was like
when Michael duus got in the tank nobody
remembers that but me but I yeah that
was that was Extreme as well yo this
picture's crazy yeah come on levitating
that's the best one for me you can see
the shadow below his foot like you can
see the heel on the ground but he looks
like he's on his tippy
toes that's crazy D come on bro
something doesn't make sense I it's kind
of like they photoshopped really well
into this picture almost it looks some
like it looks fake but it's a a tweet I
don't
know wow that's a good one someone had
to have made a fake image like be real
like that's the thing like could this
have been photosho I mean I saw the
video I watched a video of it we just
really need to find the boot maker I
mean these are this is custom who cares
it really does saw this when I saww when
you look at the boot yeah it looks like
this is hard plastic and this is leather
and you can see the shape of his foot
pressing up against it and look at his
left foot dude it is it is yeah those
are like special made he does he have
one leg shorter than the other well both
his legs are absurdly long if these
really are his
feet I don't know man I'm G to see if
they make boots for this occasion I just
know I'm not voting for him cuz he's got
weird shaped legs and looks like a he's
a good dude with a campaign doing
everything to destroy him that's crazy
to me well you know I don't see a single
DeSantis flag in Florida this is like's
home state in those trailer parks it's
nothing but Trump Trump's got the
working class down locked and DeSantis I
mean you're right I think some never
trumpers like the bush Republicans
probably got in his ear threw a bunch of
money behind him said you're going to
win and just go and then really in
reality divide and conquer yep think I
mean divide and conquer makes the most
sense they know if Trump and S his team
up unbeatable we need to make sure they
can't it oh my goodness I think I found
him looking for him too I'm like boots
to make me taller can you can you what
did you search for well I looked at uh I
looked I'm at I'm at Don's footwear.com
elevator height increase boots and I see
a pair of cowboy type boots maybe
they're not they're not maybe exactly
the same but cowboy boots there's the
austa
to and there's the canant to so there
there's a lot of boots that look like
they would serve the
purpose interesting yeah but his his
have like an inner lift to disguise it's
a dis some of these do too I want you to
know how do I find that these lifted
boots but look at
elevator elevator elevator boots for men
these elevator boots elevator boots
found them yeah that's that's
definitely no I'm looking at love to see
that crisp and GL and there's something
inside it there's something inside
that's what I'm saying it looks like if
you put put if you ever put a cowboy
boot on you put your foot halfway in and
you put your heel against the back of
the the boot you have that whole bunch
of space it looks like he's just
standing in regular boots and he has
like some socks underneath his feet or
something like that when I search
elevator cowboy boot hidden lift a
picture of Ronda
sant's the answer Don footwear.com is
where I
am.com
yeah yeah I don't know well anyway I'm
sure they exist in fact yeah I'm I'm
sure it's likely so you said when you
were in Miami people were saying they
were like hardcore
fans uh so we we ended up sell like we
we almost sold out the whole venue we
didn't quite sell up the 850 but uh in
Austin we sold out in a day and so two
things people said was Miami is too hard
to get to because it's like the it's all
the way all the way down there and it's
like oh okay fair point so even if
you're in like South Carolina you're
like that's brutal so we're we're
looking at Pittsburgh and Nashville next
which is a more centralized location for
people people who who who live in the
area they can come down from different
directions but uh one component was we
we thought Miami would do really well
because it is it has transformed so much
deep red but we did hear that there was
like a lot of people are just very heavy
on dis santis and don't want to admit
they backed the wrong horse or whatever
so they're just like ah just backing
away you know oh Tim's insulting to
santis
gotcha what is it Don's Don's Footwear
uh yeah donf footwear.com
spoke sh maker is that what it is and
then we search for elev elevator
heights yeah oh wait elevators get five
in yeah wait wait elevator oh look at
this yeah that 6 in 5
in as as poss can they also do elev 3T
extra height dude wild they they look
like stilts I think we do you see how
they and they also do get yeah there you
go and if you scroll down there's like
cowboy boots there's more
stuff oh W that's crazy but none of
these are like obviousy to wouldn't it
be so funny if I I just bought some of
these and like you know just for no
reason there are look at the r for
president or I'll be 6'2 tomorrow like
I've always been 6'2 what do you mean I
mean I have some boots that are like
this but not like even there like the
bottom height is associated with
advantages in the professional and
personal lives of most CEOs are about
average height that's like this is like
like I can ibly women are Tred as holler
men can there's all those women's shoes
that are like wedges on the inside only
like those weird high heel sneakers that
are like high heel on the inside those
always yeah those always freak me out
cuz it's like you're stuck with the
uncomfortableness of high heels and you
don't even get the visible credit of
wearing select height increase look at
that select increase
height nice 4 in
yeah crazy and then you just get the
boots dude I think we should order a
pair of these for everyone in the
company and just we'll do we'll do a
cast Castle bit where everyone's really
tall just like but everyone's like
walking like they're on
stilts yeah it's great this company
would make like 20 grand overnight look
at this look at this there's so many you
can see how they do it they've got like
you can see the shape on the outside
yeah on the inside there's that little
wedge yo that's crazy wow dude there
there there are these ads on Instagram
where they sell these inserts you can
buy them like 20 bucks and you stick
them into your shoe and then it gives
you a two-inch lift on your heel and
your shoes are like on the ground you're
like you're you're on high heels but
you're height it you're heightening and
then there's like this the commercials
are funny cuz there's a guy same height
as the girl and then they're like yo guy
got a microphone like what do you think
about this guy she's like he's all right
I guess and he's like here check this
out and then he puts the inserts on the
guy's shoes and he's like now he's tall
she's like oh yeah I like it he's like
you don't care that he's wearing that
that you know he's not really T like no
I don't care it's great I like it and
I'm like what happens when they get to
the these guys are going to buy it they
don't care I guess like well I mean you
don't really need to be tall in the
bedroom necessarily
I mean increase height 3.1 in that's CRA
on the whole time that happened on a
that actually that was another Seinfeld
episode actually really he was wearing
hiking he was wearing like what do you
call him the uh Timberlands he was
wearing Timberlands George was wearing
Timberland it made him taller and he
would never take them off and he was
like wearing Timberlands in bed he was
wearing Timberlands to a wedding yeah
all right we got to go to super chats
we're running behind before uh before we
do smash that like button subscribe to
the channel share the show with your
friends become a member at timcast no
members only tonight CU it's Friday but
we're going to read your super chats and
you can of course buy cast brew coffee
at cast brew.com to support the show we
sponsor ourselves all right Dom Dan cam
says one congratulations sir for $2 you
are the first Super Chat Clint T Say
howdy people never forget if you're
first it's because I allowed it keep up
the good work Tim and crew love what
you're doing and Clint came in second
good second place man I love this one
quisby Joe says I am become first smash
the like button no you were third then
we have uh David magdalino says take
that Clint what you were
[Laughter]
fourth uh one evil chef says Chuck
Norris for speaker I just watched all
the Expendable movies they're so awesome
I love them Expendables 4 is not as good
because Sylvester Stallone's too old he
really needed him the first three are
just so so hokey and hilarious when Arn
Arnold is like you'll be terminated you
know when I'm back and every's like and
then Chuck Norris walks out in like I
think part two and then they make a joke
like I got bit by a rattles or Cobra and
he's like after five painful agonizing
day the Cobra died and then they all
laugh yeah I thought it was great they
tried doing part four but SAS slone's
like 77 so it's yeah you know he's still
he's he's looking old man become a meme
a little bit it has definitely yeah
dimad Doom guy says when am I getting
the timcast Branded snowboard we're not
making snowboards what skateboards we
can do yeah that's that's a lot of money
Peter balk says if what Epstein says
about Google and Android is true Dr
epston do you think they had for
knowledge of the Hamas attack and did
not say anything if so was it benign
neglect or intentional to push the
agenda I do not think the that uh uh the
probability is on the side of Israel
having forn knowledge I believe that
they were warned about something and
what Hamas has stated is that they only
whispered among two or three people
about what they were really going to be
doing going to Israel and being like
there may be an attack doesn't help and
you want to play that game have someone
be like on this date someone will break
into your house good luck you're you're
it's it's defense is very very difficult
but um the yeah yeah I think I I think
Israel was was did not did not know uh
and I don't think they were using um uh
the argument that could be made for this
is that the tech they did use should
have been predictive of something but if
they're not using these things and
they've isolated themselves from it then
the machine can't track what they're
doing so I think that was kind of the
point they made how they kept it a
secret and we talk about that war game
that famous story you guys probably know
the name of it I don't where it was like
an older guy and younger guys and the
older guy won and it was because they
wrote down their instructions on a note
put it in a guy's pocket and wrote it on
a motorcycle whereas the other guys were
trying to spy over like Communications
and radio waves and that's not what they
were doing it's crazy that's interesting
David magdalino says Clint is indeed a
worthy adversary till next time theory
here big government maintains a spending
amount to collapse the Dollar by 2030 I
will not eat the bugs neither will I I'm
I honestly have no problem with eating
bugs it's just taking away people's
options and choices and forcing them to
do it right I actually think like y'all
should be prepared to eat bugs not
because of you know fake meat or living
in the Pod it's because if you truly
want to survive in a conflict or in
chaos you will do what you must yeah it'
be like someone like I do not eat the
bugs to me means you will not take away
my choice for some arbitrary reason of
control I won't be forced to right but
the or I mean look no if the system
collapses because they did it is not
what I'm I'm saying I'm like in that
case eat the bug survive you must
survive for I mean forced by somebody
else like compell compelled to is better
they're not going to stand in front of a
cow and say cows are cows are illegal
now you have to eat a bug I'd be like
get out of here I'm having cow having
beef you know I just order a whole bunch
of bong that stuff so good yeah that
South African jerky that oh yeah good
but but that's my point if it would be
like imagine uh if under the idea of
like I want the bugs I'm not saying the
argument is in the context of doing what
you must to survive eat the bugs I
recommend it don't die we need you to
live we need our ideas to survive
imagine if someone was like I will not
warm myself at the campfire I I demand
you know oil heat in central you know
Central condition this bulletproof pod
right right it's more the demoralizing
thing they want to humiliate You by
eating the Cricut biscuits and then
taking away the real meat and biscuits
they don't taste good you've had one we
had a we bought Cricut flour and we made
50-50 Cricket bread and the problem with
Cricket is that it's
astringent I'd like in the flavor to ear
wax
ew oh yeah uhhuh you ate it willingly
yeah oh you have to try it yeah of
course yeah I'm all about it uh I I
don't I I don't advocate for fake meat
or bugs forced on people but I certainly
think if you're someone who is like I'm
not eating a bug good luck when you're
when you're in a car accident in the
middle of the woods or you get lost and
you're like oh no what do I eat it's
like well you eat bugs yeah like pick up
a log and find a bug and Chow Down cuz
you need to survive like the fangi they
yeah but like yeah but even at that
point then you don't really have a
choice like you got to eat it or survive
your choice gone yeah compelled bug
eating that I'm not bug comping if the
government says making you eat debugs
and
you're still desperate either way
cricket cricket Puffs Cricket Puffs in
Canada yeah they're well in Canada they
have a um the whole industry that the
government is helping boost up and
they're making uh Cricut farms and all
of this stuff so that you you will eat
the bugs and there's um there's like
products already on shelves with uh bug
Puffs they're like cheese puffs but with
bugs Jed Richardson says Ian is doing
what props to him I'm proud of his
transformation yeah he sent me a message
let me let me read what he
said uh let's see he says he's doing
tactical training with Luke yeah full
cardio Extreme
Airsoft Ian's gonna come back two weeks
it's gonna be two weeks he's just going
to be like massive yeah wearing a cross
necklace you know just oh yeah people
don't understand exercise is addicting
this what I don't get like I don't
understand the people who are like I
don't want to exercise that's so weird
to me oh I hate exercising and I do it
every single day how do you hate it I
don't get it maybe it's I'm a dude I'm
just Bor I find it boring oh that's why
I skate cuz skating is so F yeah I need
like a better exercise you know what you
got to play pickle ball that's the new
game of the dissident right you have to
play pickle ball it is like if you are
in the right you have to learn how to
play pickle ball mandatory Robbie just
stood up in his living room and started
screaming and pointing at the screen see
I like uh I like a lot of sports that I
don't play anymore like I loved skiing
and swimming and all of these kinds of
great exercise okay biking now hold on
there a minute Ginger mcisaac says how
pray tell do you know what ear wax
tastes like are you a human being okay
when you were a little kid you never
like itched your ear and then later like
somehow was eating something and tasted
ear wax bro I'm not playing stupid games
come on humans have nasty stuff all over
their body and like ear wax and weird
stuff can can get on your hands or
whatever you're a kid I once chopped a
bunch of chili peppers and then 4 hours
later itched my eye okay and it's like
it stays classic so yeah that's how uh
uh or I can just give you the the
millennial answer of oh I was at a Harry
Potter convention I was just gonna
mention the birdie Bots
beans beans yeah with those all right
let's see uh what do we have Justin SL
says Israel bombed the third oldest
church in the world in
Gaza well um it's a it's a shame I just
don't believe anything that comes out of
uh Gaza I was reading about that and it
was um the IDF was looking into it and
they had said that they had bombed
something nearby and there was
collateral damage yeah Justin Amash I
think announced that one of his
relatives had died he was a congressman
who died in the Orthodox Church was that
the same one I think I don't know there
was it a more recent one it was an
orthodox church and it was today yeah
and it was uh the IDF was checking it
out you know this is a this is a this is
a war situation I don't believe it I
don't know what happened I I just
we didn't cover it because we couldn't
get any real as soon as the hospital
stuff happens I'm just like it's all
lies byebye have a nice day and they're
like you just blindly believe Israel
well Hamas lied about a hospital being
blown up so yes lied about a hospital
being blown up so yes committ massive
terrorism exactly they they they and now
they're playing for sympathy and I'm not
really having I'm so I'm so over it so
over it all right Bender the offender
says watched the segment with the woman
complaining her college degree in
marketing was essentially pointless I
never bothered going to college I went
to a blue collar job instead and I have
little to no debt bunch of useless
degrees from these colleges college is a
scam I feel bad so bad for these kids
it's a video where this woman is like I
have a marketing degree I can't get a
job anywhere I make more money she's
like all these jobs it's a pay cut if I
want to work in marketing I make more
money serving Sushi roles true it's like
well yeah that's a tangible job with
real Revenue coming and going and like
we can track the profits on this it's
just like she said said she
but here's the funny thing she said
she's almost 25 and she wants a job that
pays 150 to 200 and I'm just like man
these kids 150 to 200 at 25 yeah wow
that'd be wild honestly my first job I
will say I went to school I studied
theater and philosophy you know because
I'm obviously very intelligent so but uh
my first job out of college was I was
making uh literally
165 a year wow that was a long time ago
right it was yes I mean it was back in
the 1920s so it was very long time ago
well see but yes see with when it comes
to college it's a real shame that
they're pumping out car like a communist
and Marxist ideology because during Co
we learned that we need doctors on our
side we need lawyers on our side we need
people who are going to go get educated
get degrees and actually start uh making
change because we aren't going to really
even though I love trade schools and and
I think that everything has a place like
we have a place too especially in the
professional Arena and I it's what do
you need a college for huh name a job
what do you need a college for uh name a
job like uh being a lawyer you have to
have well you have to be able to pass
the bar there's one well actually you
don't you don't actually need to you can
just read the law Kim Kardashian was
doing yeah you you can actually pass the
bar won't let you into the bar like you
can pass the bar but they won't let you
into like the actual bar yeah you can if
you didn't pass college sure you don't
need to go to college to be a lawyer you
need to pass the bar to make you an
attorney that's true to be a lawy
probably probably be a doctor okay
medical school is medical school very
specific engineering uh no well no I
mean I'm not saying you don't have to
but I don't think that an aerospace
engineering company will hire you with
other degree not true well I I don't
know I'm not because I know people I
know people I know people who uh uh did
not have degrees in engineering who
worked for uh aerospace engineering
companies well out in the Mojave Desert
I know someone who Mojave Spaceport that
was really cool yeah I think I have a
video on my Instagram of it too so I
know people who worked there and did not
have degrees and were Machining parts
and working on these things all that was
necessary was the capability and
outstanding degree was not required do
you want to know when I was in any
anybody have a job when I was in
graduate school at Columbia University
one of my professors did not have a
college
degree oh really yep well of course he
didn't have a college degree I I was I
was giving guest lectures to PhD courses
with no High School diplom right after
Occupy Wall Street with the Drone
technology that we had developed look me
and my friends haed a bunch of drones to
live from them nice and we were doing
mobile broadcasting numerous
universities had me come in to give
guest lectures to PhD journalism
students and I'm like I didn't go to
high school and I was like how is it
that I have a career that I'm now
developing new technology in the space
in the field covering historical events
and you guys who are four years older
than me have done nothing nothing and
and you have 100K in debt I'm just like
okay do you I guess I would say medical
school that's the main one I I want my
surgeon going to college all the like
accountants don't even need to go to
college like you just need to P get get
your license actually educate yourself
and figure it out you need a license to
be a CPA yeah yeah you but you can get a
license like you can you can learn
accounting you can Apprentice accounting
so uh what we did with the Dron for
those that are asking was we took the AR
Parrot we downloaded the software
development kit the SDK and we then
opened it up and started uh uh basically
moving through uh uh uh like the the the
code to see how like the paths of what
it was doing um and then we had we
redirected its stream to a this is all
rudimentary this is like the early days
of live streaming so it was really
ridiculous how we were pulling this off
but we used a computer with a I think we
had a PlayStation controller or Xbox
controller to uh input the controls
which we basically had to uh program
like we had to look at what how the
controls were programmed for the phone
because it was touchcreen left right up
down and then just associate that with
the controller not not difficult at all
all of this took only a few minutes and
then the difficult thing was just it's
all duct taped together so it like
doesn't work properly until we finally
worked out the bugs I did not do the
coding I basically just um I did I did a
lot of the basic stuff and then I had a
friend of mine who did the more coding
heavy stuff but I did all the live
stream stuff so anything related to how
we broadcast which again not
particularly difficult the hard part was
actually looking at the code and the
software development kit but then I got
it to actually it was a team effort we
all we all worked on it we actually had
the Drone flying around live
broadcasting it was super cool and uh
yeah for those that are asking and then
because of that someone wrote that I
built a blimp which I never did and it
made it to Wikipedia that I invented a
Zeppelin and then no matter how many
times I said I did not Invent A zeppelin
they called it the Drone stre with the
Drone stream and then the Zeppelin had
some name and I'm like we didn't do this
and then it took like seven years to get
it removed from Wikipedia but then I
decided a couple years ago I'm going to
make it retroactively true so then we
did and then they refused to reinstate
the article claiming I did because it
was false even though it's true now wow
that's fun
anyway yeah so my my point about college
is I have too many friends who have have
have moved towards communism because of
their debt demanding Joe Biden get
elected because they're in debt and they
want the debt relieved yeah too many
people who can't get jobs because the
jobs can't pay enough to cover their
debt and the debt did nothing for them
right it's almost like that was planned
there was a whole point it's to put them
in debt so they have to they say oh
everything's unfair I can't get a job I
can't work they have to become quote
unquote Marxist in order to say like I
deserve money guys yeah but also you
know when we signed away like the we
were like 18 years old signing away huge
debts like that we didn't know that it
was a racket really and then they also
like at the same time are bringing in
all these migrants who were forcing
Americans and American students to
compete against as cheap foreign labor
pushing our wages down like the the
system is stacked against us and it
really is and you know I think
that I'm going to get probably hit for
this but I do agree in some form of
student loan relief or forgiveness
program in a way where people can pay
back their debt fairly I do I think that
there is way because a lot of people
didn't sign they didn't know I think all
interest should be abolished I
think student loan debt interest is
insane the way that here essentially we
should uh go and look at all the loans
and subtract all interest from the point
of the loan from the remainder of it and
then if it exceeds what you've already
paid you get a tax credit towards that
remaining balance so let's say let's say
you took out a loan for 50 Grand and
because of the interest you've paid back
80 and still owe 70 so we say all
interest is gone which means you're in
excess of $30,000 of your loan we'll
apply that to your future taxes mhm and
that way you must pay back what you were
given and what you spent but the
interest is predatory and that's the
compromise that way nobody gets a
freebie you still got a payback what you
borrowed but we do recognize this was
bunk and Bs yes and seas cat College
endowments so that it depends on like
the success of the student to make sure
they get paid back CU right now it
doesn't they can send a student off and
they fail at life and it doesn't matter
they're losing all this now though
because of their support for Hamas so
all these billionaires and millionaires
are like we are no longer going to be
contributing have a nice day y I think
the universities should pay off the
student loan debt with their endowments
I just think the interest I like that
just the interest I think the individual
must pay what they got I'm I I like we
can argue yes we'll forgive student loan
outs with the endowments that still
means a bunch of a bunch of leftist
Communists got 50 grand for free yeah
there's no need for that either well so
the idea is if you got $50,000 and then
bought things with it you got a degree
that degree's valuable right okay you
bought food you paid rent you must pay
back the value that you were gifted but
the interest is is is is predatory so uh
yes sees the endowments cover the cost
of all the interest from the endowments
and then the individual must pay back
their principal yeah I took out student
loans just so that I didn't have to work
full-time while I was in grad school did
you pay them back yeah well there you go
you would get a credit for all that
towards your Texas that' be nice the
interest that'd be nice I know people
who were like I took out $70,000 in
loans and I owe $100,000 right now after
paying 80 yeah I'm like what it's messed
up predatory and you know and also the
the whole corporate um structure is
rigged against conservatives like it is
so hard for a white male like a straight
white male to move up on the ladder
because everything is like competing
against him trying to push him down I
think that the system is rigged against
a lot of uh regular or orary good folks
who went to college and they aren't able
to because they're competing against H
um you know H1B Visa workers who come in
who will work twice as long for half as
much we can't compete so I think that
this both like it there's a there's a
win-win strategy here where you hire
American first you know you don't make
them compete with cheap foreign labor
you pay them a fair wage and yeah then
we could pay our debts back without
interest I liked that very much you know
and that is possible but I think there
is a way forward that is fair for
everybody to pay their student loan debt
or be able to afford it and have jobs
and working lives like you know
conservatives we all work for a living
we all have jobs for a living these
leftwing people like they a lot of them
sit at home and don't do work um there
are you know of course I'm not speaking
for the majority of them but the college
students who are complaining because
they can't afford their student loans
like they didn't really try like and
they don't really have jobs so I want to
read uh two more here CVA Buck says I'm
sorry Jeff Bader says electrical
engineering tried being one without a
degree and then CVA Buck just after him
says I'm a senior engineer at a nuclear
power plant with no degree 10 years Navy
nuke experience plus industry
certifications just now working on
degree one of the funniest things that I
think was ever said to me was after
Occupy Wall Street I get featured in a
bunch of magazines times I get featured
in times person of the year one of six
features I was featured in times uh a
nominated for times 100 most influential
people not that we care about the
mainstream media it's just like the
industry is giving me these accolades
It's featured in GQ six page spread uh
front page featured story um featured in
Maxim spin getting all these stuff like
wow look at the journalism he's doing
the new technology and everything and
then I had family members being like are
you going to go to college now and I was
like I'm I'm in the magazine for the
futuristic work and the transformative
nature of what I'm doing why are you ask
me to go to college it's just in it's
this mentality is insane to me yeah I
remember remember I had a I had a very
different I had like a like a
perspective shift um this was ages ago
at this point but uh my mom I went to
school for art I was like doing Theater
Arts and whatever other stupid stuff I
was doing and uh my mom always hated it
and she was always very critical of like
the work I was doing she was like oh you
know you're working really hard and
you're not making any money and your
brother's making all this money and
whatever else and um then I stopped
doing that and I started doing this like
you know journalism and editing and all
of this kind of stuff and she was like
honey why are you doing that you know
why that's not such a great thing for
you to do and I was like oh I will never
please the people who want me to do
something different so I'm going to not
worry about it ever again I was a
director at a nonprofit which is a job
that requires a degree you'll never find
one that doesn't and I don't I don't
have a degree there's no reason for a
degree to be a director of a not
for-profit they they have their
arguments but all of these companies are
like degree required in these fields and
I'm like I don't have one and it's just
like if well they require it but it
really doesn't require the degree in
order to do the job like I'd rather have
somebody with experience a 10 years
experience rather than a four-year
degree that they just came out I think
this is the difference between like
Boomer Gen X and Millennials Gen X and
Millennials are more likely to say I
don't care about a degree can you do the
job Boomers were more likely to say get
a degree and true we we'll go a little
bit over I just want to wrap this one up
uh in my my my perspective on this is
that Boomers didn't need degrees because
after the greatest Generation after the
world World War II we had this
tremendous economy we had this massive
manufacturing base and so the economy
was really really great right so if you
were a high school graduate you could
have a family if you went to college
you'd make six figures back then a lot
of money what happens then is a bunch of
young Boomers see their college grad
Friends making six figures and they're
like damn I should have went to college
college is what makes you money when in
reality if you don't need to go to
college if everyone around you can can
survive of a high school diploma and you
say no I'm going to college it was
likely because you were pursuing a
passion you were you were chasing after
something you you really wanted to learn
about computers or whatever your passion
is why you made six figures not the
college degree but the people who didn't
go thought it was the degree itself told
all their kids to get it Millennials and
started going to get degrees gen xers
were just like I don't care if you have
a degree dude can you do the job right
and so that's where we are now but we'll
wrap it up there cuz we're going a
little late are still like that I will
say right smash like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends uh you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast thanks for hanging out
everybody and uh Lauren you want to
shout anything out uh thank you so much
for the opportunity to come on uh
timcast I really appreciate it was truly
an honor you can check more of our
content over on the St Peters Network
that's sters.com um or you can follow me
on Twitter at Lauren witzky
de right on thank you always fun hanging
out on Fridays I'm very excited to do
some music stuff coming soon and uh
we'll likely post those clips on timcast
music you can follow that at
youtube.com timcast songs uh if you want
to follow me just at Carter Banks
anywhere um Libby I'm Libby Emmons you
can find me on Twitter at liby emmens
and you can check out all the work that
we're doing at the post
millennial.age
docomond uh anyone who's a box fan the
game is on the 21st let's uh let's win
this one guys cheers all right everybody
we will see you back on Monday but we
got Clips coming up all throughout the
weekend so thanks for hanging out we'll
see youall
then